now as far as we know 15 000 people
have died from covid uh in new york
nursing homes
as far as we know emphasis on that part
of it the number is already much higher
than the previous figure which
it turned out was being under reported
by about 50
we could probably assume that the actual
number is higher still but even
pretending
that the numbers at this point are
accurate 15 000
is a staggering figure how did it get so
bad
how could so many die especially when
they were already ostensibly isolated in
care facilities
shouldn't that have made them more
protected instead of more vulnerable
well the how has been coming into
sharper focus lately
and some revelations this week
especially have helped to reveal
the magnitude of this scandal in new
york first
the ap reports based on records that it
obtained it says
uh that quote more than nine thousand
recovering chronovirus patients in new
york state were released from hospitals
into nursing homes
early in the pandemic under a
controversial directive that was
scrapped amid criticism and accelerated
outbreaks
the new number of 9056 recovering
patients
sent to hundreds of nursing homes is
more than 40 percent higher
than what the state health department
previously released and it raises
new questions as to whether a march 25th
directive from governor andrew cuomo's
administration
helped spread sickness and death among
residents a charge
the state disputes okay nine thousand
that's nine
thousand people carrying a deadly virus
a virus known to especially infect and
kill the elderly and carrying it
right into nursing homes keep in mind
that we knew on march 25th
that the elderly are most vulnerable to
chronic virus it cannot be claimed
claimed that cuomo and his
administration didn't realize what they
were doing
or didn't understand the implications
one of the first
established facts about the coronavirus
was that it hits the elderly heart
and that it hits kids hardly at all
those were the two things we knew about
it
right away those are maybe the two maybe
the only two facts about the chronovirus
that have not changed
and yet leaders like cuomo responded by
shutting down schools
and opening up the nursing homes to
covet
why was this done what was the reason or
at least the stated reason well the ap
says this the cuomo administration's
march 25th directive barred nursing
comes from refusing people just because
they had kova 19.
it was intended to free up space in
hospitals
swamped in the early days of the
pandemic it came under criticism from
advocates for nursing home residents and
their relatives
who said that it had the potential to
spread the virus in a state that had
at the time um had the nation's highest
nursing home death toll already
okay free up space so they had they had
no choice but to send covet patients
into the nursing homes
effectively condemning thousands to
death because the hospitals were swamped
overflowing at capacity they say
well that's strange um it's strange when
you consider this
reading from a usa today article
published on april 23
2020 it says the naval hospital ship
usns comfort
is set to leave new york city city's
harbor after it floated for three weeks
mostly empty of patients projections
about the spread of the carnivores sent
new york state scrambling to increase
its hospital bed capacity
by more than double its 53 000 limit the
federal government was called in to
convert spaces like the
jacob javits center in manhattan to
overload into overflow hospitals but a
month after shutdown efforts
that capacity hasn't been stretched to
its limits
comfort and its 1 000 hospital beds
sailed into new york late last month but
was under scrutiny for being sparsely
used
of four overflow hospitals built in the
state
only the javits center has taken of
patients so far according to state
officials okay that again
april 23rd 2020. the hospital ship had
been in the harbor for three weeks at
that point
the directive to send covet patients in
into nursing homes because of
overflowing hospitals
was signed on march 25th so for the
entire month of april just about
um patients were sent to nursing homes
to free up space while an entire naval
ship floated there unused
along with four other overflow hospitals
that were also barely used
how do you make sense of this granted
i don't know all the logistical
complications of sending patients into a
hospital ship but
whatever they are whatever extra effort
or red
tape had to be gone through whatever it
would be
wouldn't you make that effort rather
than intentionally introducing the virus
into communities of elderly people
so why weren't the ships used we can
only speculate here's one speculation
that you can't help but wonder about did
cuomo choose to send the patients into
nursing
homes rather than onto the ships because
he didn't want to have to say that trump
was helping
was this all about making sure that
trump didn't get credit
you can't help but wonder did 15 000
elderly people die in order to protect
cuomo's political ego
now this possibility becomes even more
prominent when you consider another
big revelation this week this is from
the new york post this is what they
report
governor andrew cuomo's top aide
privately apologized to democratic
lawmakers for withholding the state's
nursing home death toll from coven 19
telling them quote we froze out of fear
that the true numbers would be
used against us by federal prosecutors
the stunning admission of a cover-up was
made by secretary to the governor
to the governor melissa de rosa during a
video conference call with state
democratic leaders in which she said the
cuomo administration
had rebuffed a legislative request for
the tally in august because quote
right around the same time president
donald trump turns this into a giant
political football
according to an audio recording of the
two-hour plus meeting
she continues he starts tweeting that we
killed everybody in nursing homes
derosa said he starts going after new
jersey governor phil murphy starts going
after california governor
newsom starts going after gretchen
whitmer
and the post report continues in
addition to attacking cuomo's fellow
democratic governors derosa said
trump directs the department of justice
to do an investigation into us
and basically we froze
okay if this is true for the new york
post and i see no reason to think that
it isn't
then we have an admission of a cover-up
and one of the worst cover-ups in
american history that's not an
exaggeration this is
easily without question one of the
country's deadliest political scandals
we're talking about decisions that were
made for political self-serving reasons
it would seem
that directly led to the deaths of
thousands of people
more from the post quote but instead of
a maya culpa to the grieving family
members of more than 13 000 dead seniors
or the critics who say
uh the health department spread cover 19
in the care facilities with a march 25th
state health department directive
derosa tried to make amends with the
fellow democrats for the political
inconvenience it caused them
she said so we do apologize i do
understand the position that we
that you were put in i know it's not
fair
it was not our intention to put you in
that political position with the
republicans
uh yes a political position with the
republicans
that's the concern here not you know all
the dead bodies
not the position you put your elderly
citizens in the position of
lying in a damned coffin well let's not
forget
while this was all going on infected
patients sent into nursing homes
thousands of people dying a cover-up
habit
andrew cuomo the guy behind it all was
being awarded an emmy
for his press briefings and he signed a
book deal to brag about his coveted
leadership
and he was going on cnn for cutesy
interviews with his little brother
let's all remember this you know what i
understand this is the normal swab
i'm holding up here now and for
everybody at home a very valuable object
there's only one company in the entire
country
that makes these up in maine all right
here's the swap is it true
that this was the swab that the nurse
was actually using
on you and that at first it went into
your nose
and disappeared so that in scale
this was the actual swab that was being
used
to fit up that double barrel shotgun
that you have mounted
on the front of your pretty face
see i said i was going to be nice and
sweet
i just wanted yes no and was it true i
was trying
or was it this very hard look which was
it
oh isn't that so cute and sweet isn't
that so funny
you know in hindsight that's one of the
most embarrassing moments for the
american media
ever well not in hindsight it was
embarrassing at the time too
cuomo will continue to get this kind of
treatment from the media
no matter what's revealed about it
because they're invested in the
narrative
that trump and republican governors are
the ones who botched the coveted
response
that's the narrative they cannot waver
from it but the reality is clear
there's plenty of evidence that andrew
cuomo is guilty of criminal
negligence and rampant abuses of power
he should be arrested
prosecuted immediately maybe once
they're done with this
show trial in dc they'll get around to
that but i won't hold my breath
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content